what's fair body work on Finity and
welcome to another episode of challenge
affinity this is series were you
challenge us with the craziest ideas let
table tennis if your idea gets picked
will fit truth and give you a shout out
[Music]
so make sure you leave a public holidays
in the comment section below so this
idea comes from dry ice tag we spin out
the stick and try to make our alternate
chose this is gonna be horrible I know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello Marcela wants us to play a cop's
merrily while all using our packets
let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Emmanuel Kozak wants us play with a
coffee pot so me are not the first
brought our favorite pots with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so random destroyer wife he wants to hit
a ping-pong ball through the windows of
a moving car let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching guys if you enjoyed
this episode make sure to leave a thumbs
up and if you want a spa channel even
more remember to get your own pumpkin
tea hoodies and t-shirts from the link
below also subscribe right here and
watch your previous episodes here until
next time